[Musique]
bonjour alors on entend de plus en plus
dans la presse le fait que
l'intelligence artificielle devient
créative qu'elle est capable de recréer
de la musique de reproduire fidèlement
le style d'un compositeur et sa première
bourse est pas encore complètement sûr
et deuxièmement ça va pas être tout à
fait le sujet qu'on va aborder ici même
s'il ya plein de mots clés en commun à
savoir apprentissage automatique
technologie créativité musicale
en effet là on va plutôt parler de
chercher la connexion entre l'humain et
la machine plutôt que de chercher
toujours plus d'autonomie de la machine
et puis on va s'intéresser plus à créer
produire de la musique plutôt que
recréer reproduire de la musique l'idée
c'est de se dire que c'est pas le modèle
qui créera de la musique nouvelle
mais c'est les nouveaux usages qu'on
pourra faire de ce modèle
donc si on veut faire de la musique
nouvelle ou moins pompeusement offrira
des musiciens à des improvisateurs à des
compositeurs la possibilité d'explorer
des nouvelles directions
on pense que c'est en introduisant des
nouvelles pratiques et pour introduire
des nouvelles pratiques
il faut des nouveaux instruments donc
moi et mes collaborateurs chercheurs
musiciens on peut dire qu'on est en
quelque sorte des luthiers numérique et
qu'on essaye de créer des agents
improvisateurs des agents compositeur ou
des instruments noté d'une certaine
intelligence on va dire qu'ils soient
capables d'improviser sur scène avec un
musicien ou bien d'être utilisé en
studio avec un compositeur pour
multiplier démultiplier les palettes des
possibles donc le point commun entre
tous ces agents musiciens qu'on
développe premièrement c'est la notion
de mémoire c'est à dire qu'on leur fait
manger on leur fait apprendre beaucoup
de musique ou un peu de musique avant de
monter sur scène ou parfois en montant
sur scène
est ce qu'on appelle faire de la musique
pour ces agents musicaux c'est se
promener c'est naviguer de manière un
peu facétieux et non linéaires dans
cette mémoire musicale pour créer des
nouvelles séquences musicales donc pour
illustrer sa un premier exemple avec un
saxophoniste humain qui joue du
saxophone et puis un système qui
commence avec une mémoire musicale vide
qui enregistre ce comme musicien joue
créé sa mémoire à partir de ça pour
pouvoir
et trois voix de saxophone qui viennent
créer une texture avec lui
[Musique]
non
m
là
qui
[Musique]
cet exemple-là illustre bien le premier
paradigme qu'on essaye de mettre en
place deux d'interaction de connexion
musical entre l'humain et la machine
premièrement il ya ceux dont je parlais
tout à l'heure les coûts'
d'apprentissage le système est coûteux
de musiciens pour engranger des
connaissances musicales et puis aussi la
connaissance commune d'un scénario d'une
structure en fait avancé boots et sur
l'improvisation vous avez vu là on a dit
au système on va improviser sur tel
déroulé temporel alors c'est quelque
chose de très abstrait on lui a dit par
exemple il y aura un thème appuie un
thème b puis une variation sur appui
retour sur aube et sans définir ce
qu'est a ou b mais on donne une séquence
un scénario est donné à priori un
scénario à la machine s'est pas tricher
c'est pas tricher premièrement parce que
le but c'est de faire de la musique et
pas de faire des prouesses techniques
forcément donc ya pas de morale là
dedans le but est que ça marche
et puis ce n'est pas tricher parce qu'en
fait ça reprend exactement les pratiques
que peuvent avoir deux improvisateurs de
jazz qui sont dans un club mais qui se
disent avant de commencer là on va
improviser sur la grille d'automne livre
de a song for my father par jour par
exemple
et cette idée d'introduire un scénario
dense que je vous la machine
c'est aussi intéressant dans une
pratique plus compositionnel une
pratique de composition pure ça permet à
un compositeur de composer à l'échelle
de la narration
d'où la métaphore de scénarios de
composer à grande échelle ce qu'il veut
raconter
et puis se laisser surprendre par la
manière que la ram elle que la machine
aura eu deux instances iessa de réaliser
ça c'est le cas par exemple dans le
projet le bas expérience du compositeur
pascal dusapin ou là le but c'était à
partir de grosse mémoire musicale me
constitué de plein de comptines a
capella de créer des gigantesques nuages
chantant dans lesquelles les spectateurs
déambulent là je vais vous montrer des
petites réductions avec quelques voix un
pad et sentel et donc par exemple voilà
ce qui se passe si le compositeur dit
j'aimerais avec ta machine que tu me
fasses quelque chose un nuage chantant
qui correspondent au scénario abstrait
suivant plein de tranches de voix autour
de la même note qui viennent se
superposer puis d'autres qui rentre pour
créer finalement un accord par exemple
[Musique]
et
c'est
ou bien un autre exemple de scénario
tient maintenant je voudrais un nuage
chantant qui tourne autour de tels
mélodies et qu'elle pioche est surtout
dans des timbres assez aigu avec des
voix assez clair plutôt de femmes ou
d'enfants
[Musique]
donc là l inverse du premier exemple
c'est vraiment une application pour la
composition pure et entre
l'improvisation et la composition
ce type d'outil aussi permet on va dire
d'apporter les pratiques hybride à
mi-chemin entre les deux par exemple
dans ce projet du compositeur georges
blog du pianiste hervé sellin le but
était que le pianiste puis s'improvisait
sur une structure scénario connu à la
brosse à savoir le standard de jazz the
man i love mais il voulait être
accompagné par un choeur avec une
esthétique un peu patchwork un peu cut
pour quelle raison parce que la mémoire
donnée aux agents pour constituer ce
choeur était très hétérogène
donc on avait billie holiday qui chante
de mana il offre donc ça pour chanter
sur the man i love ça devrait aller mais
aussi edith piaf qui chantent mon dieu
miller ou bien
elisabeth schwarzkopf qui chante du
mozart du puccini donc le but c'était
d'avoir ce coeur un peu bancal un peu de
guingois mais qui grâce à l'intelligence
musicale du système rentrer quand même
dans l'harmonie du morceau joué par le
musicien
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
je
oh
non
[Musique]
elle
donc dans cet exemple là comme dans les
précédents on a vu la collection la
connexion entre l'humain et la machine
par une écoute d'apprentissage et par la
connaissance d'un scénario commun
souvent qu'on peut dire c'est qu'on peut
composer par l'humain et une autre
direction qu'on étudie une autre
connexion musical entre l'humain et la
machine c'est celle de les coûts très
active c'est à dire que cette fois le
système n'a aucune connaissance a priori
du déroulé temporel de ce qui va se
passer il connaît pas de scénario mais
on le punit juste de capacité d'écouté
et d'analysé pour être capable de réagir
sur le moment de la meilleure manière
possible à un événement musical qu'il
entend donc par exemple dans cet exemple
là avec le saxophoniste rémy fox encore
ont nourri la machine avec de la
batterie et on veut que les gens
écoutent l'énergie et la hauteur de ce
que joue le saxophoniste pour être à mi
chemin entre un effet c'est à dire
parfois une batterie qui vient soutenir
supporter enrichir le timbre du
saxophone et parfois quelque chose qui
est plus de l'ordre du dialogue avec le
musicien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà ça change un peu des esthétiques
musicales et alors voilà ce qui se passe
dans ce cas là dans la tête du système
alors j'utilise plein de l'état fort
j'ai dit dans la tête du système mais il
faut bien comprendre que dans ma bouche
comme dans la bouche de plein de gens
c'est des métaphores et que c'est le
système n'a pas de tête pas de
créativité
le yoga ou quand même donc ici la
mémoire musicale du système c'est un
saxophone découpé en petites tranches
c'est tous ces points colorés que vous
voyez ici et là le système écoute
quelque chose de très différent un coeur
de poulenc et le but de cette simulation
là c'est que en écoutant l'harmonie
l'énergie et les variations de hauteur
du coeur de bouloc le saxophone puisse
dans les grandes lignes restait dans la
même harmonie suivre les mêmes
évolutions aller vers du plus aigus
quand le coeur dans le plus aigu aller
vers plus d'énergie voir la conclusion
d'une phrase quand le coeur va vers plus
d'énergie ouvert la conclusion d'une
phrase
[Musique]
et
donc j'en fond c'est un peu le clou tout
à l'heure en dix ans le système n'a pas
de tête pas de créativité etc
c'est parce que quand on voit ces
exemples là où le système écoute chez
n'a pas de connaissances a priori on
pourrait se dire ah ben là par contre on
y est à la machine autonome qui réagit
et qui crée tout seul alors de
l'autonomie il y en a c'est vrai mais en
fait on est loin du système tout à fait
autonomes parce que derrière ça déjà il
ya une interaction forte avec le
musicien rue main et puis surtout même
si c'est moins évident que dans d'autres
pratiques musicales il ya des gestes
compositionnel fort le fait de dire je
veux choisir tel corpus telle mémoire
c'est un geste compositionnel fort le
fait de dire je veux pas non seulement
de la batterie en soi mais telle
batterie sans lien aussi dire je veux
que la batterie elles réagissent non pas
aux notes que je joue mais juste à
l'énergie de ce que je fais ça ça
traduit d'un propos musical
et puis si on laisse le système jouer
tout seul il pourra déroulé un discours
certes mais comme vous l'avez vue sur
certaines vidéos
si on veut quelque chose dont la
narration pour changer donc peu évolué
il faut une deuxième personne la
deuxième êtres humains qui si le
musicien donne le stimulus le deuxième
être humain qui joue avec ses
instruments logiciel qui lui compose en
temps réel de quelle manière on réagit à
ces stimuli et donc ce qu'on cherche à
faire avec ces systèmes en fait c'est
d'offrir aux musiciens avec qui on
travaille
la possibilité d'être impliqué en amont
dans la composition du discours musical
kora le système avant la performance
ça leur permet de composer non pas dans
le temps comme une partition mais de
composer des mécanismes de composer des
types de réactions donc c'est autre
chose que la composition comme dans le
sens dans lequel on l'entend tous mais
ça reste encore une fois j'insiste
un acte créatif humain et puis quand on
travaille avec des musiciens qui sont
expérimentateurs improvisateurs créateur
bien souvent si on leur présente ce type
d'outil ils vont pas nous dire est ce
que tu peux essayer de me faire une base
tranquille qui colle bien avec les
accords de piano que je te donne la
question ça va être mais avec ton truc
est ce que tu pourrais faire une
batterie qui soit et super bien
articuler rythmiquement mais qui se cale
parfaitement sur la prosodie de mon
saxophoniste préféré ou non peut essayer
de faire ça du coup ce que je voudrais
préciser avant de terminer c'est que
tout ce qu'on a vu ici là c'est pas un
travail de chercheur isolé dans son
laboratoire
on fait tout ça en collaboration étroite
et long terme avec des musiciens et ses
collaborations ont trois objectifs le
premier c'est de faire de la musique
avec tous ces systèmes là il ya eu ces
trois dernières années plus d'une
cinquantaine de concerts avec la galerie
de musiciens que vous voyez ici à paris
au centre pompidou au collège de france
aux états unis en europe un des vrais
production musicale c'est ça qu'on
cherche à faire
le deuxième objectif de ces
collaborations c'est de produire des
instruments de produire des outils qui
au passage son open source libre sur
internet
et quand on travaille en vue d'une
production avec un musicien avec ces
outils qui marchent pas encore qui sont
encore un peu balbutiant c'est leur
retour qui nous permettent d'avancer de
motiver les développements futurs
et puis d'une troisième finalité c'est
que en creux quand on travaille avec des
musiciens improvisateurs par exemple et
qu'on leur demande pourquoi la musique
allemand ça marche pourquoi la
musicalement ça marche pas trop selon
toi ben la manière qu'ils ont de
répondre et de valider ou non ce qu'on
fait avec nos systèmes informatiques
c'est une manière détournée de leur
faire formaliser ce qu'est
leurs pensées de la musique ou leurs
pensées de l'improvisation donc c'est
une démarche qu'on pourrait presque
qualifier d' ethnomusicologique donc
c'est pour ça que systématiquement quand
on travaille avec les musiciens
on prépare les performances on travaille
en studio on fait des concerts et on
fait des entretiens et des séances de
réécoute donc ces entretiens
très souvent on entend des choses assez
tranchées de la part des musiciens avec
qui on travaille des très beaux d'avancé
lourd inintéressant au possible
voilà comme ça c'est bluffant
et parfois des choses tout aussi
tranchée mais peut-être un petit peu
moins immédiate à retranscrire dans un
système informatique
j'ai légaré et mal garées avec l'autre
ça va mieux qu avait le même mois
je veux le dire à ma mère voilà je pense
que c'est une bonne conclusion parce que
même si c'est 10 de manière très fleurie
amarante en fait c'est exactement ça
qu'on cherche à faire encore une fois
c'est pas de créer automatiquement à
l'appel de la musique crédible c'est de
pouvoir offrir la possibilité à des
grands musiciens comme bernard lubat ici
d'introduire face à eux ce qu'ils
appellent l'étrange étrangers ou ici
légaré qui est mal garées je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]